euh les chéris j'ai très très très
mauvaise nouvelle je voulais vous le
dire et franchement ça m'a flingué la
journée faute d'argent ah et malgré sa
qualification l'équipe de France de
football de petite taille ne pourra pas
participer à la Coupe du Monde quoi C
non non c'est pas du tout une banne
regardez euh elle pourra finalement pas
y participer à cause d'un manque de
soutien financier mkin euh est-ce qu'on
peut pas les aider de France de de de de
petite taille
regardez il joue hyper bien et il sétait
qualifié pour la du monde
malheureusement on va voir ce qu'on peut
faire de combien ils ont besoin ça
commencé hier ils ont besoin de beaucoup
ils ont ils ont eu que 200 € jusqu'à
présent il fallait 17000
€ ouais alle
[Musique]
allez-ye on peut plus les aider on peut
plus les
aider on peut plus les aider ah non ça
démarré pas pu trouver de de sponsors
pourtant la Fédération Internationale
payait tout sauf l'avion alors elle est
réservé aux joueurs de moins d'un,49 ou
euh et voilà et c'était la Coupe du
monde elle se'est déroulé pendant une
semaine en Argentine je suis dégoûté bah
il nous aur on nous aurait dit avant
franement regardez le témoignage du du
président de l'équipe de France de
petittenerie j'ai contacté le ministère
des Sports qui m'a encouragé au début en
disant que ce projet était un beau
projet j'ai même contact Madame Brigitte
Macron pour lui demander son soutien et
elle m'a répondu en me
disant que le ministère des sport allait
revenir vers moi le ministère des sport
n'est jamais revenu vers
moi et je vous le dis je les aurais aidé
je te jure mon Gilou l'AV pas dit avant
parce que en fait il y avait combien il
fallait mettre combien 17 cagot ils ont
essayé ils ont eu 400
€ t pas affilié à la Fédération
Française donc quand ils ont demandé des
subventions on leur a dit mais vous
n'existez pas pour nous ils ont fait
appel à la cagnotte privée à Brigitte
Macron la prochaine fois la prochaine
fois il fasse appel à nous peut-être
pour les championnats d'Europe voilà il
y a un TRC humanitaire au Maroc qui a
mal tourné 200 personnes touchées par
une gastroentérite aigu regardez une
course d'orientation caritative qui
s'est transformé en cauchemar le 26
octobre dernier 822 femmes se sont
lancées dans le désert marocain pour un
défi sportif mais au bout de 2 jours la
plupart ont commencé à avoir des
symptômes de gastro-entérite aigu plus
de 200 femmes ont été subitement pris de
vomissement et diarhée certaines ont été
hospitalisées selon Isabelle le manque
d'hygiène sur le camp est la cause
principale de cette épidémie
l'évacuation de de toutes ces toilettes
c'était un tuyau qui allait derrière les
tentes sanitaires et qui allait ben dans
une fusse qui avait été creusée voilà
ben oui oui mais je comprends pas qu tu
comprends pas je comprends pas
l'importance de faire un reportage sur
ça enfin on dirait euh je sais pas
maintenant les gens ont la diarrée et on
en
parleformation al il y a un truc il y a
un truc qui est incroyable et je vais
dire un truc parce que je vais parler
d'amour euh tu sais sa pas quoi vous
aimez vraiment votre meuf c'est que tu
vois tu peux la savoir aux toilettes et
tout bah ça dérange pas ah oui non c'est
vrai hein bien sûr c'est fou hein oui
oui parle aux toilettes ben bien sûr bah
on parle aux toilettes
on a pas dit qu'on par all aux toilettes
cel mais tu peux aller aux toilettes ta
meuf elle peut être malade voilà tu va
aux toilettes après elle voilà c'est pas
dérangant je veux dire si tu es capable
d'accompagner ta meuf aux toilettes
c'est que vraiment tu l' capable tiens
les cheveux quand il vomit tout non y il
y a un truc qui est important c'est si
vous lâchez une caisse au lit parce que
alors là moi ça me dégoûte tellement que
quand vous aimez la personne et ben vous
acceptez vous souriez mais toi ça fait 5
ans que tu as pas de meuf mais oui mais
ça fait rien tu es en train de nous dire
que l'américaine elle pétait au
litin c'est ça que tu es en train de
nous
dire en plus elle avait du Pulco mais
non mais il pous il pousse le bouchon un
peu loin parce que tu es pas obligé non
plus de sourire parce que l'autre a pété
tu peux tu on peut changer de sujet s'il
vous plaît on peut changer de sujet s'il
vous plaît pour répondre à Kelly il y a
eu quand même 15 femmes
hospitalisées mais partout dans le monde
il y a des gens hospitalisés parce
qu'ils ont la
diarrée c'est sans doute la bactérie
icolite
ils ont mangé un fruit Lavit à l'eau il
biscuité le monde dig les conditions
étaient catastrophiques c'est pas la
première fois avec cet organisateur et
elle songent à attaquer en justice le
Maroc enquête parce qu'il aurait pu
avoir des morts et beaucoup de ces
femmes étaient fragiles parce qu'elles
sortaiitent de chimio ouais parce que
c'était pour pour le ruban rose pour
lutter pour récolter des fonds pour la
lutte contre le cancer des pour les
femmes merci on a découvert une jeune
fille incroyable elle a gagné plus de
600000 € grâce à des photos et des
vidéos de ses poils sous les bras euh
regardez ça ça revient très fort
apparemment le hérisson sous les
aisselles ça revient incroyablement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
regardez
alors elle s'appelle fené la Fox elle a
30 ans elle poste son contenu sur les
réseaux sociaux et sur only fan 9800 €
par mois 600000 € depuis qu'elle a
commencé alors je pense que cette femme
n'a pas gagné tout cet argent juste
grâce à ses poils c'est juste parce
qu'elle a une grosse poitrine et qu'elle
est très belle déjà donc on va pas se
MiTo hein si une dame elle va lever ses
bras dans la rue va avoir une touffe
c'est pas pour ça qu'elle va gagner
600000 € trop facile on le saurait après
il y a aussi il il y a l'histoire des
fétichistes des esselles et des poils
comme les fétichistes et des pieds moi
j'ai été avec une copine hier qui est en
train de se de tenter le diable parce
que des hommes proposent des sommes
folles pour des orteils bon ben après
chez chacun est libre de c'est quo l'ire
business j'étais avec une copine hier et
et il y a des hommes sur Instagram qui
lui proposent des sommes astronomiques
par exemple 600 € la photo pour un
orteil quoi et elle est en train de se
demander s'il fallait qu'elle le dise à
son mec s'il fallait qu'elle le fasse
une photo de son or juste la photo c'est
vrai que les mecs deviennent tellement
dingues que que les femmes bah parfois
sont tenté de faire certaines chos qu'on
on a connu des ministres qui aimaient
bienou ouou t les tâter les orteils non
c'est que des phot copine elle se pose
la question de le faire ou pas bah elle
s'est dit moi je considère pas mon pied
comme mon corps parce que pour mon pied
c'est mon pied elle s'en fiche
totalement et elle s'est dit bah si
j'envoie mon pouce et je gagne 600 €
elle hésite il y a des des personnes bah
qui peuvent être dans le besoin et qui
peuvent être tentés de faire ce genre de
chose ça reste vendre son corps donc
c'est moi je lui a dis ça reste vendre
ton corps même si c'est ton pied
donc pas fermer gueule mais s'il y a des
demandes contactez-moi sur Instagram je
vous envoie toi tu le fais alors toi tu
le fais le fait lui qu'est-ce qu'il s'en
fout mais lui on s'en fout moi je le
ferai jamais mais il y a des fétichistes
comme ça même pour les animatrices télé
pour où effectivement parfois dans dans
les shooting photos on pose on est je
sais pas en jean Pied n Il récup il
récupère ils font des des des ouais
après la vidéo elle était quand même
significative parce que je voyais Raymon
quand il voyait la vidéo avec la jeune
fille avec les bras baissés elle avait
la bouche ouverte et dès qu'elle levait
les bras il a fait ah Berk donc malgré
tout pour les hommes non mais c'est vrai
le poil des esselles c'est c'est une
injonction des hommes et le poil
deselles est dégoûtant il y a un truc un
peu de je sais pas de masculinité ou de
saleté alors que les femmes elles
peuvent faire ce qu'elles veulent et
elles peuvent elles possèd leurs merci
merci vous êtes déjà sûrement posé la
question combien d'argent faut-il avoir
sur son compte en banque pour arrêter de
travailler et continuer de bien vivre
une étude a tenté de répondre regardez
ça ça pas de ça
être en vacances toute l'année et ne
plus subir le métro boulot dodo c'est le
rêve de nombreux français si certains
investissent dans l'espoir de prendre
leur retraite anticipé ou tentent leur
chance au jeu de hasard bienvenue pour
un nouveau tirage Loto une récente étude
vient de dévoiler combien d'argent
serait nécessaire pour pouvoir arrêter
de travailler en continuant à avoir un
bon train de vie un homme célibataire de
30 ans devrait posséder la somme de
978000 € selon un sondage réalisé par
l'Ifop les moins de 35 ans seraient
justement ceux qui rêveraient le plus de
ne plus mettre un pied au
bureau ils ont calculé ça ferait 1600 €
par mois ouais c'est ça ouais jusquà 80s
non pas sur un mec de 30 ans sur un mec
de 20 ans si tuas 20 ans à 1900 € par
mois il faudra 600 € par mois jusqu30 €
non non non c'est un homme de 30
célibataire non non un homme sélibataire
de 30 ans il lui faudrait 978000 € en
partant du principe qu'il vivra jusqu'à
0 ans ça qui fer 1630 € net par mois
1630 € net par mois donc et en fait on
peut arrêter de de travailler c'est pas
mal non ça dépend des charges que vous
avez si vous avez un
loyer 500
B mec le mec le mec il va il va il va
faire en fonction il va pas prendre un
salaire il va prendre
ser sal oui serait ça bah oui 8630 € net
par mois euh si euh il devait s'il
possédait la somme de 978000 € est-ce
que vous êtes déjà demandé vous ça non
vous vous les avez vous
pardon tu les as toi facile combien par
jour toi 78000 toi toi tu as dû en
plârer toi
TF1 ce regard d'envie que vous avez
qu'est-ce qu'il a en plâré lui je peux
te dire je peux te dire que lui rvez au
fantasmer non non non on est au courant
on est au cour monel je fais des marchés
je vais dans les grands magasins je
vends des concerts toi de notre gueule
tu vas nous faire pleurer
aussi c'est une bonne question pour pour
moi par exemple je me suis déjà posé
cette question aujourd'hui à l'heure où
on se parle pour pas travailler jusqu'à
80 ans il me faudrait entre 600 et
700000 € et jusqu'à 80 ans je travaille
plus si quelqu'un me donne 600000 €
700000 € si je connaissais quelqu'un qui
pouvait me
[Rires]
filer c'est rien du tout moi je peux
je peux faire les carreaux je peux
sortir le chien je peux faire plein de
truc ta
maison sans la maison avec les 600000 en
payant à loyeux si tu me donnes 600
700000 j'ai 47 ans je pense que je vais
au bout je vais à 80 mal non mais voyez
vous êtes jeunes tous ici mais moi qui
suis plus âgé que vous c'est une
véritable angoisse de savoir si je
m'arrête si j'ai assez pour vivre
convenement moi va te dire
arrête-toi je peux te libérer hein non
non mais c'est fou c'est une véritable
angoiss quand on une famille pauvre
issue d'un milieu modeste comme moi vous
savez on gagne de l'argent à une époque
et j'ai toujours ça en moi la peur de
manquer et je vois que même moi à mon
âge à 66 ans je me dis est-ce que j'ai
assez pour vivre si je m'arrête parce
que j'ai l'intention t'inquiète avec
Olympia t un joli cuir ah bah ouais déjà
celui-là tu le
revends on va se retrouver dans un
instant